tropicana palms offers las vegas
retirement living at its finest
last month we toured the grounds and we
had a little fun with their golf carts
i paid them another visit to learn more
about their great amenities
previously at tropicana palms did you
bring the golf cart
yes can i take it first short ride
is it out front yes it is see you linda
gotta go
[Music]
woohoo
linda hey jc so that's where my golf
cart went
how are you it's so good to see you it's
great to see you come on up i'm looking
forward to talking to you it's a
beautiful day if we sit on the porch
yeah sure all right but it's so much fun
being out here at tropicana palms
i gotta tell you the number one question
i get asked by viewers and future
residents is
what's the move-in process like here we
make it very
easy for safety precautions right now
we're offering both
self-guided tours as well as guided
tours with a safe distance
after that we determine what kind of
financing situation you may have
i've got all kinds of financing options
we have a great program right now
five thousand dollar down no prepayment
penalty
up to 25 years we've got a special for
our veterans
and sometimes we throw in a little extra
something like a washer and dryer
or maybe a big screen tv the process is
handled in the sales office
we work with a finance partner it's very
easy there's a complete package that we
put together for you and just step by
step
what are the standout amenities inside
the homes oh there's so many things the
elegant crown molding in the main living
area and
in the master bedroom the beautiful
master bath with walk-in showers and
benches
uh the two two sinks in there are really
nice
the farm sinks are a big draw and our
pantries
but don't forget that beautiful island
that you can eat in and enjoy your
breakfast and they come with multiple
options we've got three bedrooms two
bedrooms with an extended den
and something here tropicana palms that
i just love is
the activities that you have tell
everyone about the activities that are
going on well you know covent has been a
challenge for all of us
but our outdoor activities have been
open and doing well
pickleball tennis shuffleboard
bowling golf all at a safe distance and
it's
it's been working really well we just
recently have been slowly opening up
our card game our jewelry making
tai chi yoga we've got all those with
limited numbers
and when appropriate wearing masks for
safety a laundry list of amenities
because here at tropicana farms
you don't come here to retire you come
here to live
i love it thanks so much for having me
again i appreciate it oh it's always
great to see you
come back again you got it oh you know
what
since you took off with my golf cart i
need to borrow you for a minute i need
some help
good job good job little enthusiasm
i'm pretty good huh
how much longer about an hour an hour
there we go i got one i got one this is
good
close it up
i got another one
we love linda call cal am properties
tropicana palms at 702-456-5823
or find them online the address is on
your screen and remember
no payments until 2021 and only 5
thousand dollars down on a new home